it's great to welcome back to the
program michael moss
a new york times best-selling author
wrote the book salt sugar
fat new book out today is hooked
food free will and how the food giants
exploit our addictions
uh so great to have you back michael hey
nice to see you again david
so in the time since we last spoke we've
learned a lot more
about the sort of physically addictive
nature of certain
food elements we've learned about sugar
we've learned about other elements but
we've also learned a lot about
um food marketing nutritionism and so
many other aspects that that operate on
a more
sort of psychological rather than
physical level talk a little bit about
sort of your general approach to this
book and and what you're talking about
when you talk about
um addiction to food yeah so i mean i
wrote the book and
started researching it because right
after stall trigger fat came out
at the end of it i was trying to be a
little optimistic and say look
ultimately we're the ones who decide
what to eat and how much and the very
first question i got was but
michael isn't this stuff you're writing
about
addictive like drugs and if so how can
we have any control over and i was like
whoa you mean you're comparing like
twinkies to heroin i mean i was like
no way but i came full circle
in realizing and talking to experts who
coached me on this which is that
look in some ways food is even
more addictive than some drugs and
part of the reason for that is that the
companies have figured out ways to
tap into exploit if you will
our basic instincts i mean we by nature
are drawn not just to eat but to overeat
and the companies have figured that out
and turned that which was a good thing
for most of our existence
into a really treacherous thing by
making overeating
an everyday thing is um
what is the start of the chain of all of
this
is it profit motive for food
yeah i mean look i still don't see this
as this evil empire that intentionally
set out to
to make us overweight or otherwise ill
these are companies doing what all
companies want to do
make as much money as possible by
selling as much product as possible
and by making that product as attractive
and irresistible as as possible so
they have chemists working for them they
have marketing expert psychologists sort
of
all trained and focused on hitting our
biological
instincts but also our emotional buttons
to
maximize the allure of their products
can you talk a little bit about
what what exactly is it when you
research this
that that is most addictive is it is
sometimes said
you know the dopamine release from sugar
is similar to drugs is it what what
exactly is it
yeah so there's a few things one we are
built to sort of
love food that's inexpensive it kind of
makes sense right
the least put out the least amount of
energy for the calories that you're
getting
you know the industry uses these
chemical labs to come up with new
formulations that
are shaving you know 10 cents 20 cents
off the price of a package
that excites the brain um they're
really good at variety you know
we're we by instinct are drawn toward
different kinds of foods that's why
we're able to populate different parts
of the world with different food to eat
and we're really good at adjusting to
that
you know you walk in the cereal aisle of
the grocery store
there are 200 versions of sugary starch
with that soul purpose of exciting the
brain
we love calories right we have sensors
in our gut
also possibly in our mouth that detect
calories and food
and so the food companies have been
really good about
packing in the calories i mean
compare like a hot pocket to a stick of
celery and you get the idea
of the contrast between basic food stuff
and ultra processed foods and again the
break the brain gets really excited by
the more calories and is much more apt
to sort of put you into that impulsive
compulsive drive where the thinking part
of your brain doesn't have a chance to
just to step up and say wait a minute
michael i think you're going
too hard on this food it seems that at a
certain point there was a huge
evolutionary
evolutionary advantage to that in the
sense that like if you think back to
uh hunter gathering and the amount of
time and energy spent chewing in order
to
obtain a certain number of calories and
then all of a sudden you're maybe able
to
you know you you cook something and
you're so which allows you to kind of
do in advance some of the work that your
teeth and body would do
the body probably would sense that wow
one bite of this
is conferring way more calories and it
was good at a certain point
it was such an eye-opener to me spending
time with evolutionary biologists
one of whom kind of pointed out to me
look michael it's not so much that food
is addictive it's that we by nature
are drawn to eating and the companies
have
changed the nature of our food
um you know you said it absolutely body
fat
was a really good thing it enabled our
brains to grow and enable us to get
through
hard time able is to have more babies
which natural selection is
is all about and it's only in the last
50 years that we're sort of realizing
that having too much body fat will work
against you i had no
idea but body fat is a living thinking
organ and when you try to reduce the
amount of fat on your body
it will fight back in incredibly
diabolical ways it will send signals to
the brain
that you're hungry when you're not
hungry it will slow down your metabolism
it will make you get more excited when
you see
advertising for processed food and
cause you to want that food more than
you did before you had that extra weight
one of the things that michael pollan
writes about
in omnivore's dilemma is the sort of
transformation
by food companies of foods into food
products
taking for example the idea of like if
you just take corn
it's tough to make a lot more money just
selling corn maybe you can get a seed
that can be planted more densely so you
can sort of like up how much you can
grow in an acre
but like selling corn as corn is only
going to get you so far however
if you take corn break it down into its
component parts you can now
use corn syrup as an alternative to
sugar
you're adding calories and reducing cost
and you're extracting and taking all
these different elements
most people if they looked at a list of
ingredients would recognize
a lot of that stuff is highly processed
and probably not that good for you
and yet these products are all
incredibly popular so
so what are food companies doing in
order to make people want products that
if you're really presented with the
ingredient list most people probably
know aren't really the best things to be
eating
yeah i think one of the most important
things they're doing is
speed i learned from researchers who
study drug addiction whether it's
cigarettes alcohol or harder narcotics
that the hallmark of addiction is how
fast the substance hits
the brain because the faster it gets in
our brain the more apt we are to hit
that go button
and not respond to the smaller part of
the brain that's trying to put the
brakes on com
you know us doing something we really
don't want to be doing
um and so the food companies were
ingenious
in building speed into their products
both in the factory to reduce the cost
but also just the way we eat it and i
i often refer to these foods as
convenience foods because
a lot of them can be eaten with one hand
while you're doing
something else and that creates this
mindlessness mode um where you're not
paying attention to the food and when
you're not paying attention to
their products they're controlling you
rather than you controlling them
so speed is probably the most important
and most diabolical aspect of these
ultra processed foods
how does all of this apply to the sort
of
diets sometimes sometimes called fad
diets lifestyle diets that sometimes
will come in and out of favor
uh in in large part because of marketing
when it seems that
over time if you take a big picture of
you you don't really
seem to need anything so specialized it
seems that
sort of uh limiting processed foods is a
good thing
generally limiting
but not necessarily completely
eliminating animal products
isn't a bad thing to me i see
profit opportunities anytime you see a
diet that requires
a lot of one thing or none of another is
is my
my instinct right on that well
absolutely let me tell you about sort of
prophet i was stunned
to learn that the largest processed food
manufacturers
quietly bought up gained control over
some of our more popular dieting methods
and we're talking about
heinz buying weight watchers um
slim fast atkins um
you name it south beach diet a lot of
these brands and methods were acquired
none other than by the food companies
and then they kind of populated the
grocery store with
diet versions of their main line
products which really weren't all that
different than the full bore calorie
version
sitting next to each other on the shelf
and sort of
counting on us to be making rational
decisions every time we go
shopping as to which of these products
to
to to to to buy and and eat and pay
attention to but
here's the thing again that sort of
relates to that relates to addiction um
the thing about and one of the lessons
from drug addiction one i think that
makes these food products
even more troublesome than drugs can be
which is that you can't just go cold
turkey you can't just
stop eating to deal with a food
eating problem we all have to eat and
that's the slippery slope and so we walk
into the grocery store and we're
so vulnerable at times in our lives or
times of the
of the day to their marketing and
their products and these diet schemes
that look
by and large work until they stop
working which is why so many people have
trouble sticking to a diet because it's
strange and it's different and they
ultimately because the power of
memory in in escaping our eating habits
draws us back to what we were doing
before
is the uh you know most people most
people are busy people are working
people are earning a living they have to
get their kids back and forth it can be
very difficult to keep up with
is the egg good or bad right now is
coffee good or bad
is soy good or bad that is there one
principle
which is just avoid processed foods as
much as possible
that is the simplest thing for people to
remember or
or would it be something else i think it
kind of depends where you are on the
spectrum like i wrote this book for
everybody whether you're in an eating
disorder with
binging or you've got clinical obesity
or you're at the other end where you're
just kind of like troubled by like how
much attention you have to pay the food
to stay on top of it
and not let it like you know gain
control of your
of your life and i think the overall
lesson i think again a lesson learned
from the drug addiction world is that
it really helps to have a plan no matter
what it is but
to have that plan and then executed so
you know if you're hit by the proverbial
3 pm
craving for a cookie what you learned
from people who've
helped people deal with drug addiction
is you've got to like at
255 you need to be working on your
your plan whether that involves getting
up and stretching or calling a friend
or having an alternative snack like a
handful of nuts in order to ward off
that craving grease
because those cravings come on so fast
that no amount of willpower is going to
help you resist them
once they hit the reward center of the
brain so that
that pre-thought no matter what kind of
what your strategy is
i think is is the overall lesson i
learned in talking to other
two addiction researchers in terms of
now uh
all of the sugar alternatives you know
sweetened with beet sugar
sweetened with monk fruit or what
whatever the case may be
um it is is that really about
health or is it about profitability or
is it
both the companies are in this mode now
where
more and more of us are caring about
what we put in our bodies and responding
to that by eating less of their
most problematic products the companies
are responding by
cutting back on self-sugar fat but also
adding things
um to their products like protein or
fiber you know on the notion that that
might help reduce the cravings we get
for those products
sugar is really interesting to me and
i'm you know
and and the science is still new on this
and
and i wouldn't and i wouldn't bet on it
at this point but
there is concern that this move by the
industry to
replace reduce sugar by replacing it
with
fake non-caloric sweeteners
could be really problematic i mean think
about it
you know you taste something sweet your
brain is expecting
calories but your gut doesn't get those
calories
you know it's quite possible that
something will go haywire with your
metabolism so i mean if you're using a
diet soda to
really resist you know drinking a full
calorie soda and that works for you
you know nutrition was to say okay go
for it but
overall i think it's really troubling
that the companies are moving around the
entire grocery store now
trying to reduce the sugar level but
keeping
that sweetness by using these sweet
sweet fake sweeteners non-caloric ones
without
us knowing enough about the science to
be really confident in how that's going
to work in our bodies
well that's that seems to be the crux of
of the sort of nutritionism
approach that you can you can
essentially break a food down to a
certain number of calories
grams of fat uh amount of vitamin c or
whatever and what what you would sort of
get to is
a pill that has the same statistics as
broccoli
and assuming that it will do the same
thing for you when the whole
food really has something to it that may
be beyond mathematical identification
for lack of a better term
yeah i think that's so perspective i
mean perceptive of you and
i'll tell you the story in that you know
that you know the nutrition facts box on
products the labels you say that fine
print on the back of the label
not all of us can you know read it or
even understand it right
i had no idea that that fact box was the
creation of none other than the
processed food industry
right as a way of warding off our
concerns
about their products because in some
ways one of our basic
instincts too is to love information and
kind of be placated
one scientist calls us infos
and and the and the reality is when we
turn to that facts box and try to like
parse out these nutrient parts
of this food that isn't really food
anyway in the totality
we get lulled into thinking all that
data must be
really great and this is okay for us to
eat but the
nutrition facts box is is is a bit of
treachery in and of itself
no no no question about it the new book
out today
is hooked food free will and how the
food giants exploit our addictions
we've been speaking with the book's
author michael moss michael always a
pleasure speaking to you
great to see you and talk to you too
david